uh
welcome to the last step of the day we
have uh grant sonny bank from university
of michigan
where he will talk today about uh
mechanisms to procure information
without verification thank you so much
grant right great
so
welcome everyone so i'm going to talk
about mechanisms to procure information
without verification and this is uh
joint work kind of in this order with
noah burrell who's a great phd student
of mine and you ching kong and feng yu
uh
who have moved on thingies on the market
now and you should hire them
okay
so i want to i've
a bit of motivation here so uh the
setting is information procurement so we
have some set of tasks that we would
like uh answers to
and examples could be pure grading or
peer review
maybe uh crowd sensing so like how long
is the line that it's a small world in
disneyland right now
uh or surveys or crowdsourcing okay and
for various reasons you don't want to
answer these tasks within a firm right
so all these examples it's hard to just
hire
uh some employees to answer them so
instead we have a crowd that's going to
answer the the questions for us right
the problem with this crowd is that they
need motivation okay so they're not just
going to work for free or not do a very
good job so we want to motivate them
a blessing and curse is that in in these
settings they're indifferent to the
outcome they don't care what grade their
friend gets they don't care whether or
not this paper gets into the peer review
or they don't care very much
so unlike an auction where you can
motivate truth-telling by the outcome of
the auction that's not the case here and
that really differentiates it from some
of the other settings that algorithm
that game theory looks at
however the agents are strategic so they
will respond to monetary payments so we
want to pay them money to elicit effort
in this talk
the the tasks will not be spot checked
so we want to avoid spot checking the
tasks oftentimes that is a good idea you
can do that you can grade a few
assignments and maybe measure how how
far people are though even though you
have to be a little careful as we'll see
and the reason why is sometimes it's
impossible if it's a
subjective answer and sometimes it's
just not desirable like if you want to
deploy pure grading uh broadly uh if you
try to get like gold standard pure
graded questions and get them assembled
and ready it's uh it makes you not want
to do pure grading to think about doing
that okay so we want to avoid spot
checking and one thing i do want to
stress is that
in this talk i'm pretty excited about
this work and i think it really connects
theory and application and these
applications aren't just like throwaway
especially pure grading i'm hoping that
this work can be used to
have
uh you know more widespread pure grading
uh in the future so i i'm really trying
to connect the theory with the
application so for example in peer
grading students could get much more and
quicker feedback and it could really
improve learning
students
so the goals the basic goals are that
agents should not benefit from false
reporting okay we want them to tell us
the truth we don't want to incentivize
them to lie and also payment should
somehow measure the quality of reports
okay and what does this mean
it can take on two meetings one is that
in expectation if they work harder they
should get a higher payment and this
relates to motivation
if they work harder and they get a lower
payment they won't be motivated to work
hard
but also and this is kind of newer to
this talk and a little less familiar to
our community we want the
payments to be uh x post
representative of the effort that the
people put in or exposed represent the
quality of their uh their feedback
we call this measurement integrity okay
and the reason is uh in a lot of those
motivating examples we want the
compensation to be fair okay so for
example uh if you give a student uh an a
80 of the time and an f 20 of the time
that's not the same as giving them a b
okay even if it motivates them just as
well it's still not the same because
grades should have integrity that should
be reflected in the work that was put
forth they should just be randomized
lottery tickets okay so uh we want our
compensation to be fair another example
is
one way to kind of get this stuff to
work out in theory is you spot check
someone you know one out of a million
times and if they fail the spot check
you cut off their head okay
this works in theory this is not a
realistic mechanism that anybody can
deploy it's not going to work in
practice
so that's another reason we want
measurement integrity
finally it relates to detecting high
quality signals from agents which is
sometimes useful if you're aggregating
later and this is
similar but not exactly the same as raps
talk on thursday so i wanted to plug
that
so don't worry theoretical insights are
coming okay we'll talk about mechanisms
approval guarantees and a variational
interpretation of mutual information and
i'll define what those fancy words mean
and we'll i'll talk a little bit about
how it can be applied more broadly to
machine learning so it's not even just
information elicitation
and it'll give a nice broad theoretical
framework and show the theory
applications connected but first i'll
dwell a little bit more on the
motivation intuition and making it a
little more concrete
i think the theorists will be satisfied
to be like this is a good simon's talk
so let's build some intuition okay so
the obvious solution is to pay the
agents you know some loss function uh
based on some estimation of the ground
truth okay does anyone see what's what
the problem is with this like we just
like asked people to grade a paper and
he paid them how close they were to the
ta
[Music]
but what if you pay them even if you pay
them based on how far they are from a ta
what's a way that they can manipulate
their report
and win
they don't even need to clued
so one thing they can do is they can
just hedge their guess towards the mean
so if you think about it you have like
kind of a prior and then you have a
signal which is a noisy version of the
truth and so you should hedge your
answer back towards the ground truth and
this is
not just uh in theory land but actually
this works out in reality okay so this
is data provided to us graciously by
jason hartline at northwestern
university and there's four semesters of
data and what we did is we looked at the
mean squared error of the students the
average the average mean squared or the
student compared to ta but the ta graded
on these papers and we did different
ones but for
now let's just look at merge which
or sorry hedge which is purple here and
you can see that if if they just hedge
their answer which i think was 70
percent uh their answer mixed with 30 of
the prior
that on average their mean rank if they
just employed hedge instead of the
truthful strategy their mean rank
amongst the students increased by about
20. and there's the number of students
differs by semester there's
between
200 and 600 students in each semester
but any event it gets better just by
employing the simple strategy right
where we did x post not knowing anything
about the data or anything about
anything
this problem is compounded and this is
to kostas's points when you base uh
on the you you pay them a loss not of
you know some
external exogenous signal of ground
truth but based on their p the peers i
do the ground truth okay so here you can
see that hedge as more agents employ the
hedge strategy
the increase that you get in the payoff
for hedge actually increases right
because as as the other agents are
hedging the more the other agents are
hedging the more beneficial it is for
you to hedge and in fact it's uh it's
kind of a ratchet and you you'll get
back to the prior so everyone will just
report the prior that's kind of the
equilibrium in these games which is
obviously not what we want so this data
i'll explain where this data came from
and a little bit this is um
a synthetic data here
so there's a
there's a strategic
problem
and then there's the other kind of
dimension we'll look at today is this
measurement integrity so again we want
the rewards to be kind of interpreted as
a measurement of quality
so let me tell you where this data is
coming from okay so we we created a pure
grading model
and the idea of synthetic data is you
can know the true error you can know
everything so it's very very good for
you
it's based on data from this
paper by piece at all and they look they
had a lot of so it looks like real data
does okay so how is their model created
each pa each submission has a quality
which is an integer between 0 and 10 and
it's drawn from a binomial distribution
basically ten draws with mean seven okay
and then there's two types of graders
there's the passive graders
and they get a bina
a kind of a signal that's between zero
and ten that's drawn again from by a
binomial with mean of the quality of the
paper
and the active graders get a binomial
but instead of being graced on based on
10 draws from this binomial it's based
on 30 draws and we round it just so that
it's in the same space scores from 0 to
10. so the active graders have more
information the passive graders do
and
um
the goal is do these mechanisms do a
good job of identifying who put in more
effort who put in less effort okay
so
also some agents had biased reports but
i won't go into that here for the sake
of time
and uh there's 10 assignments over this
the kind of semester
and
each assignment is graded four times and
each
uh great each student grades four other
assignments okay so that's the uh
that's the setup here
yeah
oh yeah
yeah that's their right that's their
impression of the quality of the paper
so they don't they don't see the actual
quality they see a version that's kind
of filtered through
this this noisy signal this noisy
channel yeah
please do ask questions
all right here are some mechanisms i'll
describe some in a little more detail
than others the simpler ones so one is
you can just take the mean squared error
easy enough uh so you compare an agent's
report to the mean of the other agent's
reports you can try to do a parametrized
estimate of it to get rid of the bias of
the agents you can do output agreement
which is you pay them one if they agree
with the peer and zero if they don't
agree with that beer
a modification of that by faulting yurka
and redonovic is called pure truth serum
and there
it
it's like output agreement that you get
paid if you agree and don't get paid if
you don't agree but how much you get
paid is inversely proportional to
how likely that outcome is so you get
paid more for agreeing on the less
common answers
uh dmi or deterministic mutual or
determinate mutual information which was
in soda
a year or two ago by yuching khan is
another one and
i won't describe
that one very much
it's kind of a a beautiful play on the
mutual information mechanism which i
will
describe
and then there's this talk i'll talk in
the second part of the talk about the
pairing mechanism and there's different
versions of it you can parametrize it
you can not parameterize it and you can
use different uh
kind of scoring rules basically as part
of it and we look at four squaring rules
so one is total variation distance and
if you use that it's the same mechanism
as the correlation agreement mechanism
by snyder at all
and
you can use kl divergence you can use
squared hellinger distance you can use
chi-squared divergence and you'll see
how this kind of fits in later okay and
then what we did is we measured the area
under the curve
for um
using the payment as a classifier right
so each agent is either active or
passive so we can classify them so we
use the score of the mechanism as a
classifier for the uh for the agents as
active or passive and we'll
measure the area under the curve
[Music]
do any of these mechanisms use the fact
that like we kind of know what the score
should be it sounded like the beard
truth serum uses it in their description
yeah so they they use it and they kind
of learn it over time what the
distribution is and they use the
distribution in the past to kind of pay
the present round
so that one is a little more complicated
and the other ones don't
so here we vary the number of
assignments per semester so so here you
have kind of less information over here
you have more information over here but
it doesn't change too much you see mean
squared error is doing pretty well in
predicting who's active and who's
passive the next best are the pairing
mechanic the parameterized pairing
mechanism with kale divergence and
helenger squared and then kind of
there's a group down here that perhaps
are at least led by output agreement and
the total variation distance did i see a
question
right
all right so we're just looking at the
score as no
no ta information over ground truth and
we want to figure out who's active in
this passage
what what we really i mean this is part
of the measurement theory so i'm
disentangling these two things
one part is strategy proofness we'd like
these to be robust against manipulations
from the agents and the other is that
we're assuming the agents are reporting
truthfully and in that case in that very
simplified case where everyone is
reporting truthfully do they even work
then
right here we have the simplified case
we're asking everyone reports truthfully
can i tell who's active who's passive
even if everyone's playing truthfully
but without the ground truth wouldn't
take any implementation of the elements
of the equilibrium that we could
coordinate to
just skip the sign on this course yeah
yeah you can have opposite sake
right so you'll you'll get multiple
equilibria here and i'll
i'll i can talk more about that or glide
over it um
it yeah
you can you can certainly have opposite
say i don't think obviously is a big
problem in reality but certainly
the scaling of the whole thing is not
well defined right
so yeah like i don't know we could just
shift the entire distribution of scores
or
all kinds of things
you can try that that won't actually
work and we'll kind of see why
yeah so for things like outfit agreement
how many
how many categories do you have
right so here there's 10 right or 11 i
guess because it's 0 through 10. oh i
see so we're in that example
exactly
wow i'm not surprised it did that well
yeah some of these are pretty do pretty
well yeah
great thanks for all the questions
so we have kind of maybe three classes
maybe four classes there
and now we'll use the same data and look
at strategic deviations so
we consider these so everyone reports 10
this is coaster says everyone gets an a
common issue if you actually use beer
grading in classes
uh report the prior that would be
everyone report seven
uh hedge but we talked about that before
fixed bias i'm going to leave that out
they do some heuristic to try to fix
their bias
um
add noise they just take their signal
add some noise
uh merge signals so here you know maybe
output agreement on 11 signals is kind
of rough so they'll merge into kind of
good media a bad medium good paper
okay and the y average the y axis is in
the average gain in rank from strategic
manipulations
so you can see not surprisingly that if
you use the mean squared error that a
lot of these strategies very simple
strategies actually do yield
an increase in rank by the people that
employ them
okay and
so that's mean squared error this is
output agreement which is also very uh
susceptible to these uh these strategies
um
and
then there's this is the the pairing
mechanism with
the uh hellinger squared and the cal
divergence which are pretty
resistant to strategic manipulation here
you can see if over 70 of the people are
reporting all 10 then that's uh that's
what you want to do there and here even
at that point that strategy none of
these strategies help you with the kill
divergence okay so this doesn't mean
they're strategy proof but it is kind of
interesting to check it out in
more practice than theory so how does it
break
[Music]
yeah uh we'll we'll see
we'll see
maybe more surprisingly i'll talk about
this a little bit is that is that these
things some of these mechanisms actually
fail they're they have some theoretical
guarantees on them but they're actually
not strategy proof in our example here
and and
yeah so let me
talk about that now i guess um
so a lot like above zero is kind of good
below zero is kind of bad that's a
heuristic here and how far you are above
or below it doesn't matter that much how
far you below means how far
manipulating helps but how far you're
above just means how much manipulating
hurts you so anything above zero is kind
of equally good
and we see that a lot of the mechanisms
that have provable guarantees are above
zero but not all of them right so for
example output agreement
has some provable guarantee it's
truthful but it only
the guarantee only holds with some
priors and i guess it doesn't hold in
the priors that we're using
and uh the pairing mechanism as we'll
see it's strongly truthful but it's it's
kind of it's epsilon strongly truthful
and what that epsilon is uh depends on
the situation and epsilon's pretty big
here
not not helping you very much right
overall you see that the maximum
measurement integrity is gained by
algorithms mean squared error which are
easy to manipulate
but we can do
these algorithms do a pretty good job
trading off measurement integrity and
strategic manipulation so they do pretty
well but not as well so
um
it seems at least with the mechanisms we
have there is some trade-off we tried
really hard to get rid of the trade-off
or you know we tried kind of hard to get
rid of the trade-off and uh we did not
succeed
any questions there
for the definition of measurement
integrity
yeah yeah so okay so so uh all right so
this is a conglomeration of a lot of
results from a paper we use different
forms of measurement integrity which
form of measuring integrity you want
probably depends on the situation so
here so the one i showed you is area
under curve you may
want to do like a triangle pow distance
uh from some ground truth ranking you
have in a different situation or measure
the actual like
metric of distance uh so you can kind of
put your own thing here and this is an
average of a bunch of different
experiments
yeah actually question about this so
this is uh
one
but is this representative of a wide
class of examples or like how should
everything about this i i would say it's
representative of a wide class of
examples that look a lot like the
example i showed you okay so uh
so one so a few features that that
example has is that there's not a lot of
data
okay so each person's grading four
assignments
if you have a lot of data they'll all
work really well
but again the application areas that
we're thinking about in peer grading
it's not realistic to have people grade
the same assignment 20 times
i mean four is pushing it perhaps even
right um
so i think this these results would be
very robust in
the kind of uh
similar environments with uh
not a lot of data about the same
number of points things like that
okay so now we get to the theory part
yeah so we're going to talk about
the mechanism design just the setup then
mutual information connect mutual
information to variational statistics
show how that reduces to a learning
problem and then relate it back to
measurement
so our model we have this joint
distribution
d and each agent gets a signal drawn
from d
okay so they're they're correlated right
it's stochastically relevant which just
means the signals are there's some
correlation there they're not completely
independent of one another
based on their signal they give a report
to the mechanism they can lie
okay
and the mechanism then looks at all the
signals and gives everyone a payment
back
agents are trying to maximize their
utility which is their payment minus the
effort we won't think about effort much
in this talk but it's an interesting
topic
and the key assumption we're going to
make or one key assumption we're going
to make is that the payments only depend
on the reports no external information
okay
we'll be in the multi-task setting which
means that this whole operation is
repeated several times in parallel so
it's not just one paper you're grading
you're grading several assignments and
that's going to be important for our
mechanism
the multitask setting was uh
was first put forth by das guptan gauche
so that that's quite nice okay
so uh
i've switched notation to x's and y's so
alice gets some signals which may be her
commute time on different days bob's get
some signals which is his commute time
on the same set of days
then
they put forth the report which is some
strategy applied to their signals and
the payment is based on their uh their
reports
one assumption that we're going to make
a key assumption is that the strategy
the way that that alice and bob
manipulate their signals is they
they apply the same strategy to each
signal
so example would be
merge or hedge where i apply the same
strategy of each signal they're not
going to for example switch their first
and second signals we're not going to
let them do that
again the goal is we want to strongly
truth mechanism which we'll call it
strongly truthful if bay is now if the
truth telling is a bayes nash
equilibrium
and it has the highest payments
it's going to be a one-shot
game here where this all happens at the
same time
so it won't they can't do something
adaptive but they do know the
distribution d they kind of have all the
information they need
to uh to try to
boost the mechanism
from the
signal space which the report space i
should think of that's a feast
there is a fixed mapping it can be it
can be randomized so they can take half
their answers and run hedge and half of
them report all 10. that's completely
allowed like a mixed strategy like that
um
but what they can't do
really is like take this take the first
two answers add them together take the
second
third fourth and divide them so they
can't combine answers
okay and what i'll show is that we can
incentivize agents to
report truthfully this works in a very
general setting with heterogeneous
agents and very large spaces of report
spaces which has not been done before it
works well as a measurement and it
reduces kind of mechanism designed to
learning a certain production
and
the way it does this is it kind of
learns the geometry of the space it
learns which signals are kind of which
pairs of signals are close and which
ones are far okay and this is going to
this is why you can't just have opposite
day and random permutations because it's
actually learning some geometry of the
space
all right so mutual information okay so
we would like that the the payment the
the mechanism gives them if they tell
the truth is greater than the one it
gives them if they lie right
and we can represent this in the kind of
machine learning notation that i hadn't
seen since grad school it's been a while
so we have different panels here all
right
um and so over and over again alice and
bob get a signal from this joint
distribution and they push it through
alice pushes it through her strategic
channel basically to get x hat bob
pushes it through his to get y hat
so we can write this and we we have a
markov chain because y
and x hat are independent conditioned on
x here
so we have a nice
markov chain
and what that means is that we can
employ this
data processing inequality this is
something that may be new to computer
scientists double e people
know this backward and forward i'm in
the computer science variety okay so
what it says is that if if you measure
the mutual information between two
variables and you take one variable and
you apply some function to that variable
your mutual information can only
decrease
cannot increase
right
and uh again so again if so if you take
the mutual information to x and y mutual
it's greater than the mutual information
y and x hat which is greater than the
mutual information between y hat and x
for the same reason
the mutual information is defined this
way so this is the useful one part for
the here so it's
the distance the kl divergence between
the joint distribution between x and y
and the product of the marginal
distributions so in this one here we
basically force x and y to be
independent because we're taking the
product of the marginals and here they
are dependent and saying how far is how
much dependence do they have how far is
the joint distribution from the product
of the margins
and this if you write it out and
it looks like that and we'll use this
later but i'll explain a little bit more
so uh the mutual information framework
which uh duchenne and i came up with
says just pay alice and bob the mutual
information between the reports and as
long as this uh joint prior is
stochastically relevant then m is
strongly truthful right because i'm plot
employing any strategy will only
decrease your mutual information which
will decrease your payment
so
go
you can extend this interestingly you
don't have to use the normal mutual
information which is defined with kl
divergence you can use any phi
divergence these divergence just measure
the distance between two distributions
and you can use any of them to
measure this distance and this will work
out just as well as before
so two particular ones would be the kl
divergence and
the absolute value of x minus one which
gives you the total variation distance
which as i mentioned before is
equivalent to the correlation agreement
mechanism
sorry to support a discrete distribution
across the component of course
this is uh
this it doesn't have to be discrete it's
just you can measure mutual information
of of any two joint random variables
this is uh right so right that's the
next question is where the heck do we
get the distribution from we only have
draws from this thing okay so i'm gonna
that's your your your four slides ahead
of me so i'm gonna i'll i will get there
uh but first for the people are less
familiar with this i have some examples
of uh
computing mutual information so we have
alice and we have bob and they're
flipping a coin and they're both going
to look at the same point okay so
um
maybe so with half probability of the
coin lands heads with half atlant's
tails atlantis heads they both report
heads tails they both report tails
the product of the marginals well
alice's heads half the time bob seeds
heads half the time so the product the
marginal is just a uniform distribution
over the outcomes okay
so
again we're paying them the mutual
information which is the kale divergence
between the joint distribution and the
product of the marginals these are
different okay so they have a distance
that's greater than zero
this example here alice and bob are
looking at their own coin
right they're flipping their own coin
and reporting it so in this case the
joint distribution is and the product
the marginals are both uniform
and here they're the same and so the
distance between them is equal to zero
right which is good because intuitively
they have no mutual information and we
shouldn't we shouldn't be paying them
anything
the third example is the coin is just
heads on the ground they're both looking
at the coin it says heads okay so the
joint distribution is they both see
heads all the time
the product of the margin is they both
see heads all the time because
individually they both see heads all the
time and again these are the same
there's no distance between them so the
mutual information is zero yeah you're
assuming that
their observations are the only shared
randomness they have yes
right so here the the way you map this
on is you're looking at a picture of a
dog and a cat not a coin and they you
pay the mutual information to try to get
out whether it's a dog or a cat if they
report truthfully um
they'll have positive mutual information
if they just report randomly they won't
have positive mutual information and if
they report the same thing all the time
they won't have positive mutual
information
so that's some intuition for why the
mutual information should work it's
obviously a lot more
general than binary you can do it on
crazy things and we'll see uh how to do
it on crazy things in a few slides yeah
so i guess getting back to my earlier
question in terms of the scaling without
the ground truths this kind of
incentivizes them in the uniform
marginal distribution across the
yeah uh
no because remember we have the data
processing inequality so for any scaling
that they do they're not actually going
to be able to improve their h2
information
right if alice and bob both apply a
function so they have um
right here so they report some function
of the distribution
uh as long as as the general bank
pointed out as long as the only shared
randomness that they have
is uh is via this
distribution they can't increase their
mutual information via scaling or
anything like that
so it's different from entropy
and we'll we'll we'll
that would
apply right yeah and we can deal with
the continuous case here
that that's come not yet
yeah
what if
they
oh yeah uh if they if they're truthful
half the time and it's random half the
time yeah then you you could fill this
out and they'd get a non-zero mutual
information but it won't be as much as
them being true all the time
so you know
no but uh but what we what we saw is
that if they tell the truth they're
going to maximize the mutual efficiency
so they could they could lie but it will
decrease the parents
so you don't actually know how much
you're supposed to be paying them here
if they're truthful but you do know that
you're maximizing the payments
so it depends how they lie
as we see here so they can lie by
looking at their own point and flipping
it which case they're gonna get paid
zero they can lie by always agreeing in
which case they're going to pay zero
they can line by permuting their by
doing opposites in which case we're not
going to catch them in our setting here
so a big problem is how do we compute
the mutual information all we have is a
few draws from this distribution we
don't have the distribution itself
and if you have a
small finite number of reports
what you can do is just use empirical
distribution and hope that it's close
okay so
you don't know the actual distribution
but you just say okay instead of the
actual distribution i plug in the
empirical distribution okay how many
times l is involved both heads so the
point here is that this you have this
mutual information it's some function
okay it's some function of the joint
distribution the product the marginals
which is just to say how often do they
both say heads how often does bob say
heads and bobs and alice's tails etc etc
and you can just plug in an empirical
distribution that you see okay thirty
percent of the time bob said heads and
allison tails so i plug that into the
formula and i just report that
and uh
you can get
good turn off concentration balance here
so you don't lose uh that much
but four you're going to lose quite a
bit but
but generally
it's going to be long
so that's one thing you can
you can do so in this example here the
true distribution that is 50 50. but
instead they they saw heads 48 percent
of the time entails 52 percent of the
time and so um
i think i'm going to just skip so you
kind of you plug this into the formula
here and you end up adding five two and
five zero five so truly you should add
five two zero zero two divided by four
you should get one so the payment should
be one here but in fact you're a little
bit off but not too far off
so why aren't we done yet
and one reason is that the goal is is
too loose so truth telling versus uh
random may not differ by very much
okay and the way to solve this normally
is you just rescale the payments that
truth telling pays one and say zero if
they answer randomly they get zero and
you say hey we're done okay but in
practice this doesn't work very well so
one issue is a lot of times you have
limited liability that means you can't
give negative payments so if you're you
have mechanical turkeys you can't
uh this is coasters from this morning
you know the bear the hunters never get
eaten by the bears here okay so uh
there's no no negative payments
uh
and um
also this works poorly for risk adverse
agents as i discussed earlier where the
payments get really large and really
small and it doesn't necessarily work
well as a measurement okay
uh also what we what we uh
did so far requires finite x and y
and the convergence depends on the size
of the report spaces
okay so we want to do more
so we're going to use variational
statistics okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
rewrite the mutual information with
hitherto 4 looked like this inscrutable
integral
as this
equally inscrutable optimization problem
okay so we're gonna
scrutinate it okay
so
what does this say here
first notice this is an expectation over
the joint distribution this is an
expectation over the product of the
marginals
going to have a function k here which we
want it takes in pairs of reports and
produces a real number we want that to
be big
on the right hand side
my little guy is going big on the right
hand side large on the joint
distribution but somehow small on the
product of the marginals okay
notice there's not just k here in k here
this k is put through this phi star
phi star is the
is the dual the convex dual which is
defined thusly which is another somewhat
inscrutable formula that we'll examine a
little bit okay
so what we want to do is we want to
replace
this this thing here by this
optimization problem we're going to
optimize over k
i'll i'll explain why in a second okay
but
first let's see just briefly how to do
this notice here we have phi and here we
have phi star so we want to kind of
replace phi
with phi star here we have an equation
for for phi star but not but not for phi
okay
so uh these convex duals
define phi star this way
then you can take the what i did here is
i took the dual of the dual right so the
formula for the dual of the dual is just
this you just instead you just take this
formula here and you plug in phi star
for phi which i did there okay so that's
the dual of the dual
and
bench the fencil more theorem says that
the uh well first it's not too hard to
see i guess that the
the original function is always greater
than the dual the dual and actually
they're equal if fee is convex which is
always the case that we're going to be
here so the original function equals the
dual the dual which means that the
original function equals soup a k over k
ak minus phi star k
notice that see here this equation and
this equation here the only difference
is where the star is here the stars
there and then it just moved over it
here
right and that's why they're kind of
duals
all right
this is sometimes called effectual dual
inequality and we'll assume that fee is
differentiable
and if it's differentiable then
you we know how to optimize this k the
supreme that k
the supremum k
is going to be k equals of
the derivative of phi at a
okay so now what we're going to do is we
had
this thing here it has a phi in it we're
going to take the inside of this
integral and kind of rewrite it with our
dual formula okay that's
here so this is um
inside of the integral which i put here
we take the fee and we just replace with
this formula okay so we get the supremum
over k i'm i'm subscripting k because
we're to have lots of ks so i'm
subscripting the the k with x y
and then we have supreme of the
this is the joint distribution divided
by the product of the marginals which is
kind of what was in there times k
minus v star of k and then we have this
uh the
density of the
of the joint distribution or the product
of marginals on the outside this happily
distributes right so these are going to
cancel here and that leaves us with
supremum over k x y
of the density on the joint distribution
minus
v star of k times the density of the
joint
times the density of the distribution of
the product the margin is okay so this
is what we have it's maximized at this
value here which i'll say think more
about in the next slide
all right so let's just replace the
inside here with what we had previously
we get this formula here this is an
integration
over uh
d
over x and y and what we'll do is we'll
just uh take the x y outside kind of the
integral and now we get this formula
here so it's a supreme over x y so again
k assigns a value to every pair of
signals
and it should be kind of big
on the joint distribution and relatively
small on the product of the marginal
distributions okay
inequality holds when so that the
supremum equals the mutual information
when this k function is this thing here
remember
phi was convex so phi prime is
monotonically increasing right
so this says this is the density on the
joint distribution this is the density
and the product of the marginals so as
the density on the joint is large
relative the density of the product
marginals this is big and so feast prime
of this is is larger and so k is larger
on those values right so that's how
we're optimizing okay
so that is the
variational statistics one way to think
about this to make sense of it is that
it turns
mutual information into an optimization
problem
this k can be thought of as a
distinguisher right so you have two
points in space
and depending on how you look at the
points they can be closer together
further apart
and that's kind of what the
distinguisher is doing if you look at
them kind of the wrong way they look
very close if you look at them the right
way they look far apart you can't make
them look further apart than they are
right so this distinguisher if you use a
lousy k
the joint distribution the product
margins look close together
if you use a really good k they look the
correct distance apart but you can't use
a k that makes them look further apart
than they are
okay and that's important
for us
here
and if you if you kind of use the right
k
you get a plug-in estimator of the
mutual information right so if i know
what k is
then i can just take some draws
from the
joint distribution take some draws from
the product the marginals and i'm going
to get an unbiased estimator of the
mutual information
and so this is exactly what our pairing
mechanism does okay we take draws from
the joint distribution subtract off
apply k to it subtract off v star of k
applied to some draws from the product
of the marginals and this is the payment
okay and how do we get draws from the
joint distribution well we have a bonus
task and we just take alice's and bob's
report on the bonus task
and how do we get draws from the product
the marginals well we have a penalty
task for bob and a penalty task for
alice we make sure they're not the same
task
right and we take alice and bob's
reports there throw it through k and
apply fee star to it and that's what we
pay
yeah can you describe how this relates
to optimal scoring rules between noise
measurements background truth
so this is different because we're
measuring the distance between the joint
distribution the product of the
marginals which is just a different
thing than scoring rules because here we
have alice and bob and there you just
have alice and ground truth there's no
ground truth here they're just alice and
bob
there you have a noisy measurement of
the ground truth right here it's almost
like bob is like a noisy measure of the
ground truth if bob is truthful
uh there doesn't have to be a ground
truth here so this will work when
there's no ground truth we could ask for
opinions on things where there's no
ground truth
so it's i think it's rather different
from the scoring world
what's the environment
well obviously you're going to kind of
average over all of these
[Music]
is
so i i have a picture later on
i'm sorry
i do have a picture yeah so we'll see
kay for the the total variation of the
challenge
so um
that
so the repairing mechanism this is the
payment function is just uh k applied to
the
what we get from the bonus task minus v
star of k on the penalty task the
expected payment of this is
if you kind of
is equal to um
they could rely on their reports right
they don't have to report truthfully but
no matter what k we use this is upper
bounded by the mutual information
between x hat and y hat
which is bounded by the mutual
information being x and y by the data
processing inequality okay
and if we use the right k if we learn
the right k
to optimally distinguish these two
distributions then they're paying the
mutual information between x and y right
so this ensures us if we learn the right
k that we can pay them the mutual
information between x and y and no
matter what they do to try to goose us
they can't get more payment than that
so what this means is that if to get an
approximately truthful mechanism what we
do need to do
and i'm sliding a lot under the covers
here is uh approximate the ideal
distinguisher between uh under the
truthful strategy
and this involves solving this
optimization problem here
that takes us to the learning part okay
so we need to solve this optimization
problem here if x and y are finite this
is this is easy we know how to do that
uh but
what if x and y are not finite then you
can for example restrict k like we could
assume that x and y are gaussians and
then we know
the family that k should be from and
then we can optimize k only over this
family
and this is this is necessary if x and y
are infinite otherwise we're going to
over fit in our learning k
but it's uh it can
give you improvements even if x and y
are finite
because we can if we can restrict
what k is we can avoid overfitting
and get better estimates even for finite
x and y
so
this is known as an empirical risk
minimization problem in machine learning
i'm told by feng yi
and uh
and so this really and machine learning
people study this a lot know everything
there is to know about it
uh or not everything but a fair bit
and so for example k could be a neuro
net and then we could you know run
machine learning neural net things and
perhaps learn for a very large set of k
how to optimize uh this how to find an
optimal k for a very large class of
hypotheses
a slightly weird side note
is that
the agents want the mechanism to learn a
good k in certain situations this is
what we saw on the first summary slide
agents can help by lying they can if
they can lie to help the age the
mechanism learn k they can improve their
payment
so an example would be
if we're over fitting and not learning
this k very well they could uh group
their answers together
and we'll learn a better k because it's
easier because the the space is smaller
and it'll fit less and then they'll
actually improve their payment so that's
a that's kind of a
bug
if we don't have enough data we need to
kind of regularize properly
so this is really neat and what uh
another really cool property here of
this mechanism is that so far we've
assumed that there's alice and there's
bob okay and they answered all the same
questions now in the model i gave you at
the beginning people did not answer the
same they did not grade all the same
problems they graded a random set of
four problems and we wanted to pay them
so what we're going to do here is
imagine is x is a
agent i signal and y is every other
agent signal okay now we want to pay the
mutual information between i signal and
everyone else's signal how are we going
to compute that this is a big space we
certainly can't like just look at a
matrix
okay so all we need is the probability
of x conditioned on y and the
probability of x and that's enough
for us to compute k of x y which is all
we need to run our mechanism
okay why is that well what we need is
the the ratio between the joint
distribution the products the marginals
d prime of that you know how to compute
v prime
and this is just equal to the
probability of x conditioned on y
divided by probability of x so what we
can do is we can learn some soft
predictor so we take half the data split
it out learn some soft predictor to
predict x agent i signal given everyone
else's signal
and to predict a distribution over that
and then
for the particular y we plug that in we
get a distribution over x's that we've
predicted
we choose the x that alice actually
reported and we get probability of x
condition on y
okay
and then we still have to learn
probability of x
so technically for the for the strategic
guarantees you have to guarantee that
you're learning the soft predictor
correctly
but in in that's why in our little
practice uh
um
[Music]
agent-based model it seems to well work
pretty well and for the parametrized
mechanisms
okay
so uh why is this working a little bit
well so we have this scoring function
here
uh
the quality holds when we have this k is
this ideal what does this ideal thing
look like
um
did i lie do i not have oh i don't have
the
right answer here i can i can look it up
after the talk uh sorry but uh so this
we have gaushin's joint distribution
between alice and bob here and then we
have uh this is if we use this uh convex
function a minus one absolute value then
uh there's kind of two sections and
alice and bob are kind of paid one if
they land in the same section and minus
one if they land in different sections
that's kind of how the payment works and
notice that there's kind of good things
about this payment and that doesn't have
long tails can't mess up too badly
you're just paying them one or zero but
it's also not particularly nuanced right
if we take the kl divergence we get a
much more nuanced
payment system that scales with exactly
how much they agree
[Music]
however on the tails maybe you can mess
up a little bit more
so one just a quick philosophical
comment
is that
a lot of the previous work like the pure
truth serum tried to create simple
mechanisms that you could explain to
people this work is taking on a
different sort of quality we're giving
up on simplicity
and explaining the mechanism and instead
we're getting measurement integrity this
might be good for example if the agents
can't really reason about what's
happening in the mechanism anyhow and
they try it out and they say oh i worked
harder this time and i worked less hard
the next time but i got paid more when i
worked less hard so i don't believe this
mechanism right so you may want
measurement integrity for agents kind of
trying things out this is related to the
dynamical systems talk that we saw this
morning
but there's a there's a kind of a
different philosophy that's going on in
this work
versus previous works
okay just to
review so i can show my picture again so
in the finite case you can just minimize
the empirical risk minimization or you
can split the data and kind of learn kn
part of the data apply it to the other
part of the data
in doing this you can restrict the space
um
we can apply this even if the agents
don't answer the same questions okay we
can use different fees in our in our
feed diversions and we look at total
variation distance scale divergence
squared hellinger and chi-squared
divergence okay so this is just a
reprise of this
slide here so you can kind of see
that the parametrized one when we had h
with the head of hellinger squared did
the best on measurement integrity
followed by the kale divergence and
these both had very strong strategic
properties when we don't parameterize
we're overfitting and strategic
deviations are helping and again those
deviations are ones where the the agents
are helping the mechanism learn the
correct k
so
um
let me just talk briefly about some
future directions
so one would be more rigorous study of
measurement integrity
we have agent-based models it'd be nice
to have math
there is a
budding science of this for proper
scoring rules that people are starting
to do this is a this is a harder setting
um
we assume that agents are strategic in
practice they they may not be strategic
you can imagine your students some of
them are going to try no matter what
some of them are going to be strategic
some of them are just out to lunch some
of them want to mess up your class
because they don't like you okay so
uh we might want to be robust and not
assume that all agents are strategic we
have work on that at www last year
we may want stronger truthfulness
guarantees besides epsilon strongly
truthful so for example uching's dmi
mechanism obtains much stronger
guarantees but it doesn't work very well
for measurement integrity maybe there's
a best of both worlds to be had there
snyder at all in their correlation
agreement show a setting where basically
it's reasonable to assume that you know
k a priori so you know this
distinguisher and assuming that you know
it you have this unbiased estimator and
you get kind of stronger guarantees
we didn't model effort very much here i
have ongoing work kind of trying to take
effort more seriously how to get effort
how to incentivize effort from people we
looked at this multitask setting that
requires that you have different tasks
that you're evaluating you can also look
at the single task setting where you
only have one question at a time that's
obviously a little harder you tend to
ask agents for a little bit more
information about what they think other
agents are going to report
um
and there's there's work on that and
finally there's work on the the cheap
signals uh so
you notice that uh
max said well what if the signal space
is richer than the report space that
that can be a problem so you can imagine
agents decide they're supposed to be
pure grading based on the quality of the
essay but they're just grading based on
how many grammatical errors there were
there were right so there's a cheaper
signal and it's easier to agree upon and
if you pay the mutual information of
that cheap signal it's going to be
greater than the mutual information of
the signal you're actually seeking which
is a problem
we have
part we have
solutions to this that are maybe not
fully fleshed out yet
and also you could try to combine them
with uh tas and some ground truth checks
uh but this is still a pretty active and
interesting area of research
so lastly um
there's lots of applications of it you
can relate to
machine learning and the noisy data
problem which i won't talk more about
now to social choice
and jamie morgenstern has a nice paper
on archive suggesting how to apply this
stuff to peer review and my my favorite
one though is is pure grading and i i
hope that this stuff really works
in real life and we can uh we can help
help students
uh
learn better there's there i feel like
we really are getting close and there's
really not that many uh hard theoretical
not
unassailable theoretical challenges
yeah they seem there doesn't seem to be
any any big
roadblocks but there is neat theoretical
work
uh
remaining to be done and i'd be happy to
talk to people about that and the rest
of the workshop so thanks
[Applause]
thank you ken
so we're bringing up
the floor two questions
very interesting uh stuff so i guess
i have a more high level question about
the uh you know application uh
so like what are the
in your opinion the big challenge isn't
actually
uh
a system that works
like in view of all the work yes i think
there's
two
so one is uh integrating so we have tas
we want to integrate them and i think we
can integrate them to kind of help deal
with the cheap signal problem
uh so how to do that i think that's uh
one big one the other big one which i
haven't variously haven't thought about
so much
i think it's somewhat straightforward
but i'm not sure which is we don't want
to just elicit numerical grades from
people we won't actually want good
feedback
right the question is how to get good
feedback and for example in peer review
i think you can just
rate the feedback right because you're
in a good situation where you're already
supposed to have read everyone else's
review anyhow
so now you just need to give the reviews
a numerical score which will then itself
be part of
the system are you accurately grading
the reviews of other agents
um
so i think those are the the two
main
things this is a cheap signal and then
we don't want to just elicit a number we
want to make it into a system
and a follow-up question
i was always curious i mean i guess you
know like
maybe you're teaching class at a place
where people are reasonably strong
presumably
there are scenarios where you have to
study the trader for
how much effort the team has to put in
given the expertise in the audience
right so
you know teaching a kind of intro theory
class
one feeling i've had is that it should
be easier to grade the problems and to
do the problems because if the student
can't recognize the correct answer they
certainly can't get a correct answer
um so
i haven't seen the pure grading
literature about this but my my hope is
one that peer grading is pedagogically
useful people learn stuff from pure
grading and two that it's actually
slightly easier to pure grade than is to
do the problem because as you point out
you have a range diverse range of
students we love them all and some of
them are better at the work than others
and how well can you
put people who don't quite understand
what's going on and have them grade
something is
is
an open question
about the application so i thought that
in some places you have to pay the
students before like the tas before
like
don't you pay them before they do the
work so do you have to then give them
some bonuses based on the quality of the
work and how large do those bonuses have
to be related to the baseline oh the
idea is that this would be
the idea that this would be employed for
students grading other students for the
tas you kind of assume they're in the
firm and are doing a good job
you can
double check their work
perhaps okay doing this but the idea is
not to compensate tas based on the
quality of their work that's not
and it will violate all kinds of union
things
[Music]
for
for example and this is in jamie's paper
too
[Music]
by grading other students assignments
you may be able to get your own
assignment graded and maybe you can turn
it in as many times as you want to
until you're happy with the pure grade
result and then you turn it into the
professor to be graded
and so
the reward they're getting is not
monetary here which is not going to work
with students
and maybe not even based on their grade
but based on how many times they get
some benefit of of turning in their own
assignments so they get some some useful
utility and it's the same in peer review
we're not going to pay you money to peer
review we're going to allow you to
submit 17 papers to
nurips instead of the normal two
i have a question that has to do with uh
maybe issues of bounded rationality so
for example like in mechanisms that that
may give like very fine-grained like pay
of differences maybe this does not
something like that meaningfully
registers on the student right
so how like uh yeah could a theory
somehow like account for some some
behavioral models like that
yeah i mean that's
one of the motivations behind the
measurement integrity is that uh
if
if the signal is very noisy right and i
try hard on one and i try less hard on
the other and i can't pick up any signal
in the feedback i get back that's a
little disheartening if measurement
integrity was perfect it would perfectly
pick that up and be able to say oh
you know you you slacked a little bit in
this one we noticed that um so that's
where
that's one of the motivations of
of measurement integrity so
there's
you know a
i think empirical question of
how much measurement integrity do you
need to get this to work and how often
how much do people need to grade to get
that level
of measurement integrity but uh
certainly that's one of the motivations
behind measurement integrity this
question uh have you even
tried to test it in a simple
like multi-agent model where you say
like okay i make this assumption about
how people respond and then yeah
yeah so we um so we have the area under
the curve thing and it took us
a fair bit of time to figure out to
disentangle the strategic
part of it from the
um measurement information part of it um
and we could definitely as a follow-up
kind of run
more
synthetic experiments or agents are
trying out different strategies of
working hard or not working hard
actually there's a paper by raf
that does something very similar to this
uh using replicator dynamics
and some of the peer prediction
mechanisms but it's it doesn't have the
latest and greatest
mechanisms in it now
any other
it seems like in this setting in order
to estimate the mutual information you
need many graders or sorry multiple
graders be creating the same
students work but you might also have a
trade-off where you want to
you maybe have a limited supply of
graders and you want them to grade as
many distinct
works as possible so as their work on
there is some work on that uh
yang liu and yuling chen had a paper and
i think there's work that unless for
real from databases on that like
and their
solution is to kind of use a machine
learning algorithm to try to learn the
features and then use the other people's
machine use the machine learning
algorithm to kind of
so
you're going to predict it's back to the
multi-agent setting here
essentially uh wrong one
launched it
where did you go where you're using
you're learning this um
where you're
all you need is a soft forecast for x's
for the for the x and so you don't need
people to have graded that particular
assignment as long as you can get a
forecast so maybe you can use the
machine learning algorithm to do that
um
i think there's more work that needs to
be done there for example
are these grades predictable because
they're they may be more predictable due
to the flaws in the machine learning
algorithm that people can kind of pick
up machine learners not going to know
this but they are going to know that
it's an interesting like um research
question it was in my last grant
proposal
but i haven't i haven't gotten around to
that one yet uh but yeah that's uh
there is some there is some stuff on
that
but it's not there yet
uh